there's nothing more annoying than a
baby crying a plane car honking is just
so obnoxious most annoying noise in the
world is my mother's voice any sound
that wakes me up isn't unpleasant sound
the squeaky noise when you have friction
on balloons the original nokia ringtone
when someone handling styrofoam as a kid
I used to be scared of the thx sound in
movies land you're just like why is no
one else freaking out right now
he'll be number one I want to say babies
crying so I feel like that's pretty
universal I think it's just gonna sound
like a really bad like Nine Inch Nails
saw like a unreleased deep track
it's definitely one of the worst but it
also kind of sounds like a rusty
swingset other suck that is really
really thought fine-tuned to warm its
way into your into your brain I could
take that but like baby crying for an
hour I couldn't take I still think the
THX no is a scarier styrofoam is worse
for me so the person who decided to
record this noise you
my mom's voice is like a cat that won't
stop scratching what are you gonna get
married I want grandchildren I didn't
sound so much money on Cheesecake
Factory